the Russian President Vladimir Putin has
ordered a 36-hour ceasefire in Ukraine
for Orthodox Christmas it is set to come
into effect on January the 6th the
Kremlin is calling on Kiev to do the
same the Russian Orthodox patriarch
kiril initiated the request
well earlier Turkish president erdogan
held phone conversations with President
Putin and zelenski if Kiev accepts it
would be the first ceasefire between the
warring Nations since Russia launched
this Invasion almost a year ago
well let's go live to Kiev now and our
correspondent Charles Stratford it's one
thing Charles Vladimir Putin suggesting
a ceasefire is another thing of course
Kiev accepting what more can you tell us
about their response
well certainly at this stage it seems
highly doubtful that Ukraine would
accept
such an offer from President Putin as
you say this initially comes from a
suggestion made by the uh the Moscow
patriarch kill Russia patriarch kill
there looking for this 36-hour ceasefire
from about well from midday which
effectively would be on Orthodox
Christmas Christmas Eve right the way
through the next day Christmas Day until
12 midnight and it was a response to
patriarch Carol's suggestion
um that we heard from an advisor in the
president's office Mikhail podaliak and
he just called this a cynical trap so we
haven't had any official statement yet
by president zielinski but one can only
assume that it's going to be consistent
with what Mr podialiac Mr podaliak said
I mean just to give you a little bit of
background here there's a very increa a
very interesting sort of Change of
Atmosphere in Ukraine that is gathering
Pace
um in as far as a move away from
fundamentally an Orthodox Christmas here
because many ukrainians associate
Orthodoxy with Russia and by default
Russian aggression so for example
Christmas that has just gone by the uh
for the for the Julian calendar that now
is being gradually pushed for by many
people in Ukraine to be celebrated on
the 24th and the 25th there's also the
issue that in 2019 the a Ukrainian
Church basically was set up established
that has no affiliation whatsoever with
the Moscow patriarch it's part of this
movement to move away from any kind of
association with Russian Orthodoxy in
the wake of what the ukrainians say has
been well now nine years of war so let's
not forget that that the problem started
the fighting really started in 2014 in
donbass and Crimea and there's also the
additional issue of the fact that New
Year's Eve New Year's Day saw some of
the heaviest bombardments by Russia
using drones and cruise missiles trying
to attack infrastructure we understand
here right the way across Ukraine and
has crippled much of that infrastructure
and left a lot of people in darkness
without heat or electricity so it seems
highly highly unlikely at this stage
that the Ukrainian government and
Ukrainian military will agree to such an
offer by President Putin
Charles many thanks Charles Stratford
live in Kiev there